one of the things that's becoming more
and more clear as we learn about
michael cohen's sentencing memo from
robert mueller and
as we see donald trump's erratic
reactions and we see conservative
pundits like jennifer rubin say they
predict predict that donald trump's
going to resign and try to get
a pardon from mike pence in the midst of
all this
this is a sort of constant
that we see which is that donald trump
jr
appears to be in really big trouble why
do i say that well
because every new piece of evidence
every new piece of testimony every
new document that we see related to the
trump-russia indicement
indictments look like they're saying
that
don jr lied and therefore should be
expecting
an indictment and specifically it seems
that donald trump jr lied to congress
about the trump family's business in
russia
this is not like some esoteric idea
there are members of congress who are
plainly saying
donald trump jr lied to us here's just
one example this is democratic
congresswoman jackie speer check it out
do you think donald trump jr lied to
your committee
i believe he did about
i don't really want to go into it at
this point but i think there's at least
two occasions when he lied to the
committee
so in addition to these lies there's
more and more legal scrutiny over donald
trump jr's involvement
in that trump tower meeting that we've
talked about so much
which once again seems to have been much
more significant than initially reported
remember that trump jr
first said there was no meeting
then he said okay there was a meeting
but it was about adoptions of russian
children
then his emails were released which
confirmed that he had foreknowledge that
the meeting was taking place
with russians and it was specifically
about dirt on hillary clinton
don jr seems to know that he's in
trouble i think it was last week or the
week before that i reported to you
that uh he's been telling friends that
he thinks
mueller is going to indict him and the
latest news is that
donald trump jr is hiding out in canada
to avoid
the media if and when this possible
indictment happens which apparently
could be very very soon
that last uh this is sort of like the
last bit of this story
and the prediction is that the bomb is
close to dropping
and don jr wants to be out of the us
when it happens gabriel sherman who has
done
some really good reporting on this wrote
in vanity fair that the trump
family overall is expecting things to
implode
this week or next week and that don jr
specifically is saying
i'm out of here for now we've been
talking about this for a while pat and i
think in one of our polls wasn't don jr
the winner of the most likely insider to
next be indicted
yeah so there was don jr there was roger
stone
there was maybe jared kushner but don jr
certainly won out and i would have to
agree with that assessment listen
maybe don jr could seek asylum in canada
claiming he's the victim of political
prosecution
of course but by his dad's own justice
department
or something obviously i'm kidding
canada wouldn't accept that as an asylum
claim
by the way there's also an extradition
treaty between the united states and
canada so
just hiding out in canada also wouldn't
work the most
interesting thing for me about a don jr
indictment
is how it's going to set trump off i can
only
imagine pat that trump will
lose his mind if don jr is indicted and
it's going to be
a new unraveling of tweets and
obstruction
the likes of which up until now we've
likely only dreamed of
if this happens i think certainly things
are going to accelerate either
trump is going to think about or maybe
act on firing robert mueller
or we at least know that mueller is
close to wrapping things up and coming
out with his final report because if
you're going to start indicting members
of the president's family
i think you're pretty close to coming
out with your final assessment
something to look forward to i just hope
that they include this in the finale of
season two and don't wait until season
three to get to this stuff because i
don't want to be kept hanging in that
way over the new year